ever heard the same behind every great
man you'll find a great woman you ever
heard that before if that is true the
opposite has to also be true no let me
kind of get into it by the way some of
the ladies watching this you may not
like it some of you are going to love it
fellas
this is a message for you pay attention
and pay attention very very closely if
you get value from this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe let's get right
into it behind every defeated man you'll
find a woman who ruined his life this is
something I tweeted this week I want to
read the whole thing again stay with me
behind every great man you'll find a
wonderful woman behind every defeated
man you'll find a woman that ruined his
life is this true let me continue There
are two ways men get castrated one is
surgical the other is emotional when
marrying the wrong woman the wrong woman
can ruin a man's life you can see it on
his face no man knows how to act when
they get married for the first time
there's not a manual for it I call this
the last appointment syndrome whoever
you talk to last before going to sleep
will dictate your future Pat how could
you say this I mean this isn't fair
isn't the opposite true as well you
should you shouldn't the opposite be
true what if a woman that also marries
the wrong man because could a girl also
ruin her life by marrying the wrong man
absolutely however the American System
protects the woman and there's a greater
risk for men to get married than a woman
to get married and that's just the truth
okay there isn't any more of a way a man
can show loyalty to a woman meaning to
say that I'm all in with you once they
have a kid to give them they're married
because one tax code I took the biggest
risk two I had a kid with you I took the
biggest serious what else do you want me
to do to show you my love right now some
of you may say well Pat you can't be
saying that what isn't the opposite
truth is what would women with this with
that of course the opposite can be true
with your friends your cousin who you
hang out with for women all that other
stuff but in Iran men are protected so
women have to be careful who to marry in
Iran if a woman divorces her husband and
leaves doesn't get half of what the
husband has the husband doesn't give
nothing to the wife in Iran if he
doesn't want to because the law defends
man in America Western Society defense
women so if a man is married to a woman
in the ultimate Way by law and taxes for
men to show that the liability purely
financially is through getting married
and having a kid with a woman you're
financially tied where you have to take
care of that person if you don't have an
optional agreement in place which means
in America the man has to be careful who
to marry because she can totally ruin
your life if you marry the wrong person
that's in America okay so now if you
listen to this right now Pat what should
I be looking at number one take your
time for me as a man in America if you
want to get married 30 to 40 the right
age take your time there is no
competition you know the race like hey
let's you can run 100 yards hey let's
you can do the 40 in marriage no one
cares how soon you get married at 18 22
28 or 32 no one cares you can take your
time get married at 35 get married at 38
at 31 at 30 you are fine doing it too
early you don't have enough experience
because marriage comes doesn't come with
a manual as much as your mom your dad
your friends your peers are going to try
to tell you how to get married and how
to do it the right way 99 of whatever
anybody tells you about marriage you're
gonna have to go through it yourself so
pumped up break take your time look at
the things that matter physically does
she need to be attractive to you it's
important number two values and
principles best be common you best
believe in similar values and principle
how to raise family how many kids
financially who's in charge who makes
the decision where do we live travel all
of those things matter and if you do
that part correctly and you choose the
right one you'll have higher chances of
doing something big in your life I
cannot tell you how many men I saw
killed it in their careers were doing so
well suddenly they married the wrong
person and everything went down I've
seen men who were regular guys average
guys are always making 80 grand year 60
Grand year 40 Grand Year all of a sudden
they marry a woman that believes in them
next thing you know 300 600 a million
running 20 million out of your business
because somebody behind closed doors
saying baby I believe in you baby let's
make it work baby you got this I got
your back you're amazing and he's doing
his part the guy's got to do his part
he's got to go and do his part but
behind closer somebody is saying I
believe in you somebody behind is not
nagging negative all that other stuff
that combination together you see big
things happening with them so again I'm
expecting a lot of people to not like
this but I'm expecting many many more to
understand this message and receive it
properly if that's you and you received
it pump the brakes take your time
marriage is a big decision don't wing it
I'm a guy that's pro-marriage I'm a guy
that's got four kids I'm a guy that
loves Partnerships but I'm a guy that
also doesn't encourage to do it and wing
it take your time with that decision so
if I got you thinking those of you that
are thinking right now saying this kind
of does make sense give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel I got another
video I want you to watch the rise of
weak man if you've never watched it
click here to watch it take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]